SCP-173 - It’s one of the most iconic anomalies
ever contained by the SCP Foundation.
This neck-snapping Site-19 celebrity is known
and feared by everyone who works at the Foundation
since being contained in 1993, its nubby,
concrete hands metaphorically, and quite literally,
stained with the blood of countless people.
But this mostly immobile oddity wasn’t always
a resident of Site-19, and the story of how
exactly it ended up there - and more importantly,
why - is far more ridiculous, insane, and
downright terrifying than you could ever imagine.
So buckle up, SCP Fans.
This is the dramatic tale of how this homicidal
piece of modern art ended up at the SCP Foundation’s
largest containment site.
To give you an idea of just how weird this
origin story is, we’re gonna have to leap
forward to the year 2045.
We know what you’re thinking: Isn’t this
a prequel?
How can it take place in the future?
Sit tight, folks, it’ll all make sense in
the end.
Site-91 is where we lay our scene, under the
watchful eyes of Site Director Dr. James Long,
a senior researcher with Level 4 Security
Clearance - the second highest at the Foundation.
Dr. Long had given decades of devotion and
his expertise to the Foundation; he was a
proud man, who wore his life of service to
the containment cause as a badge of honor.
After years of dodging death while researching
some of the most dangerous anomalies that
Site-91 had to offer, he had ascended to the
rank of Site Director which represented the
culmination of his life’s work.
And in his new position of power, he’d only
proved himself further - running a tight ship,
and reducing the number of containment breaches
across the board.
Nobody could say that Dr. Long wasn’t extremely
talented at his job, which is why he was so
confused when he received an email from Alexandra
Nala, an Administrative Assistant working
directly for the O5 Council.
It was the type of email that no Site Director
ever wanted to receive: Dr. Long was being
told that, with no input or oversight from
him, the majority of Site-91’s anomalies
were going to be taken to an undisclosed location
for “Safer Containment.”
The list contained nearly every meaningful
detainee contained on the site, including
of course, SCP-173.
This particular anomaly had been contained
at the site for 37 years after being delivered
there in 2008.
Dr. Long had devised a perfect method to minimize
containment breaches in that time - creating
a sprinkler system within the chamber that
washes away the waste products produced by
173, reducing the need for risky human contact.
But that didn’t matter.
Despite Dr. Long’s loyalty and efficacy
in serving the SCP Foundation, the decision
had already been made, with no chance of reversing
it.
According to Nala, the motion to remove most
of Site-91’s anomalies had received unanimous
approval from the O5 Council, and the operations
for the transfer would be commandeered by
the Department of Extra-Universal Affairs,
headed by Senior Agent Sven Kisch.
Dr. Long was both upset and confused.
He was producing some of the best results
across the entire Foundation, so why were
they taking away all of his anomalies?
Did someone on the O5 Council have it out
for him?
Dr. Long replied to Nala, asking if - considering
how severe the relocation operation was going
to be - whether he could get more information
on where the anomalies were being moved to,
and why.
He felt that, at the very least, he was owed
some answers on this.
Nala and her superiors didn’t feel quite
the same way.
She replied that Dr. Long sadly didn’t have
the clearance to know any of the operation’s
particulars - this information was reserved
for those with Level 5 Clearance, and members
of the Multi-Universal Department.
All that Dr. Long needed to do was stay out
of the way, and everything would be taken
care of for him.
But that wasn’t enough for Dr. Long.
He needed to know more.
He needed to understand why this seemingly
random decision had been made.
Realizing that Nala and the O5 Council were
a dead end as far as information was concerned,
he instead reached out to the next best thing:
Senior Agent Sven Kisch, the member of the
Department of Extra-Universal Affairs who
was spearheading the relocation mission.
Dr. Long implored the Agent to give him extra
information on where all the Site-91 anomalies
were being moved, and why they were being
moved in the first place.
Predictably, he was once again stonewalled,
being told that any information regarding
the project was above his level of clearance.
In a move that seemed decidedly spiteful,
Agent Kisch signed off by saying that he looked
forward to seeing Dr. Long at Site-91.
And not long after that, he did.
Agent Kisch along with a huge number of agents
and task force members from the Multi-U Department
arrived on site, bearing state of the art
containment equipment.
An exasperated Dr. Long wasn’t able to glean
any more information from this experience
- the Multi-U agents were ruthlessly efficient,
transferring the lion’s share of the anomalies
into temporary containment and transporting
them off-site within a few hours.
By the time they were done, Dr. Long and his
staff were left with one of the most desolate
and empty containment sites on the Foundation’s
books.
Here was Dr. Long, with decades of service,
and climbing the organizational ladder, only
to be left as a glorified babysitter for a
handful of low-priority anomalous items.
It all felt like a cruel joke.
After several days of nothing happening in
the now-incredibly-uneventful Site-91, a bored
Dr. Long reached out to a friend of his - Researcher
Nurul Shafiqah binte Ahmad Ibrahim, whom he
called by the nickname Shaq - to vent his
frustrations.
She commiserated, sharing her sympathy for
his suddenly much less exciting working conditions,
but saying that at least the job should be
a little less lethal now.
Shaq didn’t know it yet, but on this particular
point, she was terribly wrong.
Dr. Long shared his theory that perhaps some
sites were being consolidated so the Foundation
could save money, and that this would lead
to layoffs.
Shaq essentially told him that he was worrying
too much.
The reality was that Dr. Long had some very
good reasons to be worried, his problem was
that he hadn’t been worrying about the right
things.
In Foundation Containment Area-179, something
awful was brewing.
As usual, guards posted around SCP-2317 - an
old door containing a portal to another world
- waited while Foundation staff and D-Classes
performed the standard Procedure 220-Calabasas
ritual within.
They were dealing with one of the most dangerous
anomalies in the entire universe, but even
then, after decades of service, one can become
numb to such things.
Suddenly, without warning, the door opened
and a terrified Foundation researcher tumbled
out, panting heavily, eyes bulging in existential
horror.
He screamed the words that he had long hoped
would never be spoken in his or even his children’s
lifetime, “It happened!
The chains have broken!
The Devourer is free!”
The siren sounded, and an alert spread out
across the entire Foundation database: SCP-2317
is compromised, SCP-2317-K - the Devourer
of Worlds - is free.
If the creature escapes Area-179, an XK-Class
End of the World Scenario is basically assured,
so all efforts will be taken to make sure
that the creature does not escape at any cost.
And they really did mean any cost.
The old wooden door of SCP-2317 splintered,
as an immense, scaly hand sprang forth, and
clawed a wave of devastation through the containment
chamber.
Guards were dispatched in the hundreds with
heavy weaponry to buy some time, firing as
the Devourer, a beast the size of a mountain
rose from the ground, staring at the terrified
humans below with its one gigantic red eye.
It couldn’t even feel the bullets, explosives,
or incendiary and laser weaponry being used
on it.
The monster just shrugged it off, and murdered
nearly all its attackers with one swipe of
its claw.
In a final desperate act, hoping to kill or
at least slow down the beast, staff at Area-179
made the ultimate sacrifice, and detonated
the entire on-site nuclear arsenal.
The explosion disintegrated the entire facility
in an instant, and unleashed a radioactive
shockwave that carried destruction for miles.
But it wasn’t enough.
SCP-2317-K walked out of the mushroom cloud
without a scratch on it, ready to show the
human world what real destruction meant.
At this point, the battle was already effectively
lost, but the Foundation refused to go down
without a fight.
They dispatched all available mobile task
forces - including Mobile Task Force Nu-7,
Hammer Down, a heavily-armed, battalion-strength
task force created to combat the biggest and
most extensive threats imaginable.
And it wasn’t even just the Foundation - true
existential threats have a way of uniting
people, as the GOC and even the Chaos Insurgency
temporarily put aside their differences to
take the fight to the Devourer.
But would any of it be enough?
Barrages of cruise missiles and ICBMs did
nothing to halt the Devourer’s assault,
as it rampaged, destroying towns and cities
at first, then regions, then whole nations.
Swarms of scrambled jets and helicopters were
knocked out of the sky with casual swipes.
The creature bulldozed over landscapes teeming
with tanks and heavy artillery vehicles.
It snapped aircraft carriers in half as it
waded from ocean to ocean, systematically
destroying everything in its path.
Even satellite-mounted orbital cannons and
the heavy energy weapons of MTF Tau-5, also
known as "Samsara", did nothing to faze the
Devourer.
It was finally coming to fruition: The dreaded
XK Class End of the World Scenario, and none
of the Foundation’s expertise, advanced
technology, or limitless resources could do
anything to stop it.
They aided in evacuation efforts, getting
as many people as they could out of harm’s
way as the Devourer rampaged and destroyed,
but even that was doing little more than borrowing
time.
Eventually, the Devourer would destroy all
of them.
There would be nothing left.
And all Dr. James Long could do was watch
helplessly from an almost empty Site-91, waiting
for the tide of destruction to reach him.
Of course, other Foundation employees - most
prominently, Senior Agent Sven Kisch and the
Multi-U Department - had other concerns.
All they needed to do was archive data for
extraction.
Extraction to where, you ask, seeing as the
world seems to be at its end here?
Well, Universe 7392-Epsilon-Blue-Lima, otherwise
known as our universe, circa 1993.
The Foundation works across the multiverse,
and an XK-Class End of the World Scenario
in one universe really isn’t necessarily
a problem in others.
On the orders of the O5 Council, Agent Kisch
and his men are charged with extracting data
and valuable anomalies like SCP-173 from doomed
universes.
O5 knew that Dr. Long’s universe - Universe
5643-Gamma-Orange-Delta - was due for an apocalyptic
visit from the Devourer of Worlds any day
now.
That’s why the Multi-U team went in to extract
everything worth saving.
Dr. Long and the millions of other Level-4
and below employees of that universe’s Foundation
were never told of their impending doom.
After all, that sort of thing could probably
lead to unnecessary stress.
And what they don’t know won’t hurt them
- until, of course, it does.
In 1993, these anomalous, doomed universe
SCPs were divided among our universe’s various
applicable containment sites.
SCP-173, as you already know, ended up in
Site-19.
But sadly for the people working there, all
the actual data on this entity’s file was
lost in translation, so as far as they knew,
173 was little more than a big, weird statue
with apparently dangerous properties.
Upon first placing it in its containment chamber
in the Site-19 Euclid Wing, Foundation legend
Dr. Bright, unaware of just what he had here,
assigned Dr. William Motto to begin research
on the entity.
He recommended that the Researcher bring two
D-Classes for testing.
When Dr. Motto was faced with the anomalous
entity’s blank file, he gave a sigh, and
began to write something in its description
box: “Moved to Site-19 1993.
Origin is as of yet unknown…”
Wasn’t that a delightful little tale?
Now we know how SCP-173 made its way into
Site-19, and what our own universe may have
to look forward to in 2045.
So remember, if you ever see Agent Sven Kisch
planning a transfer of anomalies out of your
site, maybe consider using some of that PTO,
and maybe consider putting a downpayment on
a nice, cozy apocalypse bunker over in Iceland…
Know of other tales you’d like to see us
cover?
Let us know down in the comments below!
The SCP Foundation specializes in tracking
down and containing anomalies that are difficult
to find, and that often will do anything they
can to avoid being found.
One anomaly in particular hates being seen
more than anything, and will punish anyone
who looks at its face with a horrific fate.
SCP-096 is a mysterious creature, not only
because it destroys anyone who sees what it
truly looks like.
No one is entirely certain where it came from,
what exactly it is, or why it reacts so violently
to being perceived.
There are, however, several theories as to
the Shy Guy's origin, and none of them are
particularly cheerful.
Some suggest an experiment gone wrong, others
believe it to be the last remaining member
of an unknown species of mountain-dwelling
humanoids.
But one theory about SCP-096's origin stands
out as particularly tragic in nature.
In this story, SCP-096 was not always a long-limbed,
pale beast cowering in the corner and hiding
its face from the world.
It was once an ordinary man, like anyone you
might pass on the street.
He was someone's son, someone's friend, a
person with hopes, dreams, and passions.
A human being who, through anomalous circumstances
beyond his control, was made into a monster.
Many years ago, there was a mountaineer named
Jack.
All his adult life, he had been obsessed with
reaching higher and higher peaks, climbing
every mountain he could in order to test his
limits, pit himself against the power of nature,
and bask in the sweet reward that was the
view from the top.
It began as a sport, a way to build up strength
while taking in incredible natural beauty,
but over time as he conquered increasingly
difficult challenges, it became an obsession.
Like every obsession eventually does, climbing
mountains began to take over his life, driving
everything else away.
He struggled to hold down a job, his marriage
fell apart, and his relationships to his friends
and family became increasingly distant and
strained.
Still, he couldn't bring himself to care much.
He spent his time alone in the wilderness,
or every so often embarking on trips with
other mountaineers.
Whether he was going at it solo or working
with others, he was living for the climb.
Over the years, he took on Cerro Torre in
Argentina, The Eiger in Switzerland, and Denali
in Alaska.
He especially enjoyed climbing in extreme
cold, braving the ice and snow as he embarked
on his climbs.
The few fellow mountaineers he kept up with
gave him the nickname "Jack Frost."
After years of refining his craft, building
his strength, he set his sights on the highest
mountain in the world, his personal white
whale: Mt.
Everest itself.
It was one of the deadliest climbs in the
world, with its staggering height, storms,
and frozen graveyard of fallen climbers dotting
the snowy surface.
But he was determined.
He would not join the ranks of the fallen,
but instead, be one of the victorious that
reached the top of Everest and came back down
in one piece.
He could feel it in his bones.
Jack arrived in Nepal with a pack full of
climbing equipment, the best boots money could
buy, and layers upon layers of clothing to
keep himself warm on the journey to the summit.
He lowered his goggles over his eyes, summoned
his courage, and prepared for the incredibly
difficult climb.
The cold seeped into his core, the winds nipped
at his face, numbing his nose and leeching
through his gloves and boots as he went, but
Jack pressed on.
He welcomed the sensation, the bite of it.
It was a reminder that he was still here,
that he was still alive.
As long as he could feel the pain, he knew
he was alright.
He knew that it was when the cold faded away,
turned to paradoxical feelings of warmth and
sleepiness, that a mountaineer was truly in
trouble.
As he navigated the harsh mountain landscape,
Jack occasionally let his eyes drift off course,
taking in the sights around him.
He could see shocks of blue, green, and red,
the distinct bright colors of boots, jackets,
and hats belonging to the fallen climbers
that came before him.
Those who collapsed from exhaustion, who gave
in to altitude sickness or succumbed to the
cold.
"Memento Mori."
He said softly to himself.
These frozen bodies represented that ever-present
reminder of mortality, of death lurking just
out of sight.
It would not come for him though.
Not today, not on this journey.
He wouldn't let it.
The hours blurred together within the crunch
of the ice beneath his boots, the dig of climbing
hooks into the earth, the tug of his trusty
ropes as he ascended ever higher.
Jack came to a stop.
There was no next step to take, nowhere higher
that he could go.
He had reached the summit.
The white whale was captured, and Everest
was his.
For the very first time, he was truly on top
of the world.
Now that he had made it to the highest point,
there was the all-important task of climbing
back down.
At this altitude, he was still in the "death
zone," the place where human acclimatization
was impossible.
This was the tricky part, the point at which
even the most experienced of climbers might
get lost in the euphoria of the achievement
might let their attention slip.
Any mistake during his descent, any misstep,
could be the thing that cost him his life.
There was no room for error and no time to
waste.
Just as Jack prepared to make his descent,
he saw a figure pulling itself over the ridge.
From a distance, it looked like a fellow climber.
He noted the curious lack of equipment, and
the way the person seemed to be making their
way up the mountain with nothing but their
hands, but perhaps they had lost their pack
or left it behind for some reason.
The figure was dressed in all white from their
hood to their boots, with a large pair of
black mountain goggles covering what little
of their face wasn't concealed by the hood.
Uncertain if the figure was in need of assistance,
and surprised to see another soul on the mountain
with him, Jack waved at the figure.
"Everything okay?"
He called.
There was no response, but the figure turned
to look at him.
At least, he thought it was looking at him.
He couldn't see its eyes through the goggles,
but he felt the distinct sensation of it locking
its gaze with his, just the same.
As soon as the figure turned to look at him,
Jack began to feel strange.
The pain, the sharp sensation of the cold
that he relied on to ground himself and remember
he was really here, began to blur around the
edges.
The feeling softened, melting away along with
the ache in his muscles, the bleariness in
his eyes, the dry mouth that had nagged at
him for hours.
He felt unbalanced, unmoored, a ship with
no anchor.
He couldn't explain why, but the sudden relief
from the cold made his chest tighten with
primal terror.
He did not feel like one man encountering
another on the mountain.
He felt the way he had years ago when he came
face to face with a mountain lion, staring
down a predator and remembering all of a sudden
that humans do not naturally sit at the top
of the food chain.
This figure, this thing...it was no man.
It was no person.
Jack prepared to continue his descent, to
get away from the strange intruder as quickly
as possible, but his feet would not obey him.
His eyes could not break contact with the
figure in white that was slowly beginning
to advance toward him, one slow step at a
time.
It was in no hurry.
It knew he was not going anywhere any time
soon.
He trembled as the figure drew closer, its
inscrutable face hidden beneath its hood and
behind its goggles.
He wished he could see its face, but dreaded
learning what secrets it was hiding.
If only he could just unstick his feet from
the earth, break free of this spell that had
fallen over him, he could escape.
But no matter how his muscles strained, how
he gritted his teeth with effort, he couldn't
get away.
As the entity came closer, the cold snapped
back into his body- but something was different.
It was heightened, like every icy breeze and
freezing wind layered on top of itself, hardening
his muscles to rock, crystallizing the very
blood in his veins.
He felt as if his fingers, if he tried to
wriggle them, would snap off and fall to the
ground.
His eyes thrummed in their sockets, his lungs
struggling to hold onto each breath as the
cold constricted its fist around his chest.
He opened his mouth to speak but his voice
died in his throat, coming out in a weak whisper
of air.
Now, the thing was close enough to touch him,
and whatever force had been holding him still
and upright released him.
It was as if he were a marionette suspended
in the air, and the puppeteer released his
strings all at once.
He crumpled to the snow-covered ground in
a heap, his cheek pressed into the earth,
his eyes trained helplessly on the still-advancing
figure.
His lips formed the word "please..." though
he could not tell exactly what he was begging
for.
His life?
His freedom?
A painless death?
He struggled to push himself to his feet,
but all the strength had gone out of his limbs.
He could barely lift his arm, let alone handle
the weight of his whole body.
The thing shaped like a man was right above
him, glowering down through those opaque goggles.
He still could not see its eyes, but somehow
he could feel the way it was looking at him.
Hatred was radiating off of it, disdain and
pure, unadulterated malice.
Then, it tilted its head to the side thoughtfully,
and Jack's mind was overwhelmed with images.
He felt the phantom sensation of sunlight
on his skin, and springy green grass beneath
his bare feet.
He could see, clear as day in his mind's eye,
a forest clearing in the middle of summer,
dewdrops sparkling on the petals of wildflowers
blowing in a gentle, sweet breeze.
Then, he felt sand between his toes, smelled
the sea breeze, felt the comfort and contentment
of a nap on the beach.
It was not offering these things to him, but
something like them...something like peace.
It was offering him...a gift.
But he didn't want it.
He couldn't take it.
He was Jack Frost, dammit, he thrived in the
cold, the hardship.
He didn't want some warm, sleepy fade out
of existence.
If he went out, it would be on his terms,
doing the thing he had dedicated his life
to.
If he were going to lose his life, he wouldn't
roll over and just give it up.
It would need to be pried from his frozen
hands.
With every last bit of strength, he twisted
his head away from the entity's gaze, covering
his face with his hands.
It grabbed at him, shaking his shoulders,
trying to force him to uncover his face and
meet its gaze once more, but he didn't budge.
He wouldn't.
He couldn't.
Then, he felt the energy shift as it realized
he had refused the gift, that he would not
welcome the paradoxical feelings of heat and
security and slip away as it was asking him
to.
But it was not a victory.
He swore he could hear a voice in his mind
say, "Very well...you wish to be part of the
mountain?
I will make it so."
The world went white as Jack's eyes rolled
back in his head, his spine curving back until
it snapped.
His jaw cracked and distended, his arms and
legs stretched out long and twisted, his body
contorted at unnatural angles as the entity
began to rearrange his very being.
As the agony ripped through him, snapping
his bones and tearing his muscles, Jack kept
his face cradled in his hands.
He remained in that position even as he cried
his voice hoarse, as the pure fear and pain
overwhelmed his senses, until he forgot his
own name, forget he was ever a man at all.
When Jack was no more, when something else
sat there in his place, pale and shivering,
body wracked with sobs, the King of the Mountain
turned and left him there, alone with his
misery.
Still, he would not uncover his face.
He would not let himself be vulnerable, would
not look up.
Days later, a group of mountaineers reached
the summit of Everest and spotted a hairless
figure crouched in the snow, weeping softly.
"Are you alright?"
One of them asked.
The figure lifted its head slowly, and locked
eyes with the strangers.
Its eyes widened in horror, its mouth stretched
impossibly wide in a wordless scream of rage
and hurt, and, with nothing human left in
its mind or heart, SCP-096 took its very first
victim.
Robed figures with hidden faces stand over
seven young women, tied up.
The robed figures chant phrases both arcane
and profane.
The leader among these dark cultists clears
his wicked throat and says, “Be not afraid,
girls.
You are here for something wonderful.
To beget seven perfect children for the Scarlet
King…”
How did we get here, and more importantly,
what happened afterward?
In the near-constant darkness that follows
the grim but necessary work of the SCP Foundation,
there is one bright light that can always
be counted on to keep hope alive, to bring
a little sunshine into everyone's days: SCP-999,
the Tickle Monster.
The sweet, simple creature does nothing but
provide an endless source of joy, hugging,
playing, and delighting in loving everything
around it.
But what if I told you that this slimy little
friend has hidden depths?
A tragic history that seems impossible to
reconcile with the happy, playful being we
all know and love?
How could 999, the happiest SCP ever, have
a sad backstory?
Well, it's one of the best-kept secrets at
the Foundation.
Before we get to that, let's talk about a
Foundation researcher and her brand new job
- a new job that would make her privy to some
highly classified Foundation secrets.
Dr. Izzy Collingwood was delighted to wake
up to a call informing her that she had been
appointed to one of the most coveted positions
at the SCP Foundation.
After applying, crossing her fingers, and
hoping for the best, she had been promoted
to Head Researcher for SCP-999.
What could be better than attending to the
kindest, gentlest, cutest anomaly in Foundation
custody?
Gone were the days of coming into work and
wondering if she'd leave in one piece.
No more cleaning up toxic spills, fighting
to contain killer creatures, or fetching cups
of coffee for old doctors that wouldn't give
her so much as a "thank you."
Years of hard work had paid off.
Now, she could rest on her laurels and do
work that she truly enjoyed.
There was just the matter of some simple paperwork,
and she would be ready to begin this extremely
welcome new chapter of her professional life.
When she walked into her office to get started
on the paperwork, something unusual caught
her eye.
There was a small stack of files on her desk,
with a sticky note attached to the front.
There were just two words written on the note,
to indicate what might await her inside the
folders: "The Truth."
She scoffed at first.
"Very funny, guys!"
She called out the door.
But no one responded, no one came forward
to take credit for the elaborate joke.
Maybe they were playing the long game, or
maybe... she couldn't be sure.
She sat down, flipping the first folder open.
It was untitled, unlabeled, just plain text
on a page.
She almost closed it after a brief scan, but
the words "The Scarlet King" jumped out at
her.
She had worked at the Foundation long enough
to hear that name more than a few times, often
spoken in hushed tones, as if merely speaking
his name would bring about some kind of disaster.
As she dug deeper into the file, she realized
just what she was looking at: the proposed
origins of the Scarlet King himself.
It was a folkloric explanation, one her scientific
mind struggled to wrap around, but she had
seen so many strange things over the years,
things that defied all rational explanation.
Perhaps there was some truth to be found in
the myths.
The Scarlet King had, according to the file,
once been an elder god born from the earliest
days of existence, in the shadows of the Tree
of Knowledge.
He had devoured his brothers and sisters,
growing stronger with each one he consumed.
As his strength increased, so too did his
overwhelming pain and hate, his deep desire
to destroy the Tree of Knowledge and all living
creatures.
He declared himself the king of darkness,
and, through a series of horrific events,
took seven unwilling brides and bound them
to him with magical seals.
Each bride bore supernatural children, powerful,
terrible, and monstrous.
The first bride, A'tivik, had only a few children.
Those few were skilled strategists, exceptionally
wise in the ways of war.
The second bride was A'ghor, overcome with
constant despair and desolation.
Her children conquered with massive, unthinking
armies, never sated and never quelled.
The third bride, A'distat, hated her sisters
and all she surveyed.
The fourth bride, A'zieb, took the shape of
a great beast.
Her children followed in her stead, and were
invulnerable, their thick hides impenetrable
by physical or magical means.
The fifth bride was A'nuht, blessed with a
strong mind and cursed with a fragile body.
Her children were gifted in the ways of magic,
and incredibly destructive.
The sixth bride, A'tellif, would not speak.
She kept to herself, and, like her, her children
moved in silence, disguising themselves as
whatever they wished.
The seventh bride, however, was different.
A'habbat was her name, the smallest of the
seven, with an unbroken spirit.
She birthed mighty heroes that she trained
in secret, in hopes that one day they would
overcome her family's darkness, and topple
the King from his throne.
All the while, the Scarlet King wages his
unholy war against all things, waiting for
the day he can arrive in our realm and unleash
absolute destruction.
Dr. Collingwood shuddered as she finished
reading, an undeniable chill passing over
her.
This definitely wasn't some kind of prank
or hazing ritual.
This was something dark.
Something real.
She held secrets in her hands, and she couldn't
stop reading them now.
She opened the next folder.
It was a description of a cult, monitored
and raided by the SCP Foundation, called "the
Children of the Scarlet King," also known
as Group MENDES.
During a sixteen-month investigation of the
anomalous religious group, the Foundation's
undercover operatives were able to ascertain
a great deal of pertinent information on the
group.
What they found was troubling, and of great
concern.
The group had ties to several wealthy benefactors,
as well as links to extremist paranormal groups.
Their set of beliefs was relatively simple
and disturbing: they worshipped the Scarlet
King, and were devoted to supporting him in
his battle to destroy the Earth and all life
as we know it.
The faithful who followed him in this task
would be rewarded handsomely with positions
of power in the new, hellish world.
An initial estimate put the cult's membership
at approximately eight thousand members, a
quarter of whom belonged to the group's primary
branch in Alabama.
The reporting on the cult was detailed, far
too dense, and heavily researched to be fake.
Again, she had the distinct feeling that someone
was trying to tip her off about something
the Foundation hadn't wanted to be widespread
knowledge.
With shaky hands, she picked up the final
file.
What awaited her inside?
There was only one way to find out.
She flipped it open, and began to read.
It was a file on an entity known as SCP-231,
specifically SCP-231-7.
An addendum was attached to the beginning
of the file, reading: "All personnel assigned
to SCP-231-7 must rotate out for one month
of psychological counseling after two months
on-site.
SCP-231-7 is to be kept at an undisclosed
location.
All personnel assigned to SCP-231 will be
transported there blindfolded from Site-19
by a route including no fewer than seven different
forms of transportation, including but not
limited to aircraft, automobile, underground
tunnel, and several we cannot discuss here.
Removal of the blindfold during the transport
process is grounds for immediate termination.
Personnel assigned to SCP-231-7 must undergo
heavy psychological testing before being cleared
to enter the site.
Individuals must score at least 72 points
on the Milgram Obedience Examination, be unmarried,
have no offspring, and express nothing less
than total loyalty to the Foundation.
Normal psychological screening procedures
against Axis II disorders are waived, so long
as the Class-D personnel in question has the
mental capacity to carry out Procedure 110-Montauk
as needed.
Personnel who express sympathy towards SCP-231-7's
plight and/or express a desire to rescue or
sympathize towards SCP-231-7 will be transferred
to another project without delay.
Any actual rescue attempts will be met with
immediate termination.
Personnel who have served on the staff of
SCP-231-7's Containment Team are not required
to divulge that information to others.
No official record shall be kept of the names
of any staff assigned to SCP-231-7, nor will
said service appear in the personnel files
of said staff.
While on-site, individuals assigned to SCP-231-7
will be issued concealing helmets with integrated
voice changers to protect their identity.
On-site staff are not to remove said uniforms
in the presence of other staff members.
Off-duty hours are to be spent in private
quarters alone.
Six Class D Personnel are to be assigned to
SCP-231-7 each month for the purposes of carrying
out Procedure 110-Montauk.
Violent criminals are not to be used for this
purpose due to the possibility of accidental
fatality during the 110-Montauk process."
Dr. Collingwood swallowed the lump of dread
in her throat, her palms beginning to sweat.
SCP-231-7 was a young woman, retrieved during
a police raid on a warehouse owned by the
Children of the Scarlet King.
She was one of seven women found there, the
first of which went into labor 24 hours after
being rescued.
She did not give birth to an ordinary child,
however.
She gave birth to a monster that took the
lives of dozens of civilians.
She did not survive the birth.
The second woman was lost shortly after, also
succumbing to the dangers of the creature
waiting to be born from her womb.
One by one, the survivors, the women chosen
by this cult to become the new brides of the
Scarlet King, fell.
Soon enough, there was only one left.
SCP-231-7, kept contained at a Foundation
Site in a hospital bed that she could never
leave.
Dr. Collingwood's stomach churned as horrible
images flooded her mind.
The notes from attending researchers in SCP-231's
file insisted they were doing all they could
to save the woman, to free her from her fate,
but that there was little they could do.
Each birth opened a gateway from this world
to another, to a world of darkness and despair,
and they could not allow the final seal to
be broken.
Simply putting the woman out of her misery
would cause the effect to jump to a new host,
a new bride.
There was nothing to be done.
The file fell from Dr. Collingwood's hand
as she pushed herself to her feet, running
out into the hallway.
"Who put these on my desk?"
She shouted, her voice echoing in the empty
hall.
"Well?
What do you want from me?"
But no answer came.
Slowly, she returned to her office and sank
down into her chair, haunted by what she had
read.
She had seen horrific things in her time at
the Foundation, but nothing that had shaken
her to her core quite like this.
The silence in Dr. Collingwood's office was
broken by the sound of a tinny beep, coming
from her computer.
She turned on the screen, and saw the source
of the alert: One New Message, from O5 Command.
What could they possibly have to say to her?
Could it have something to do with the files
that had wound up on her desk?
She accepted the message, quickly completed
the mandatory multimodal biometric ID scan,
and began to read.
"Hello, Doctor Collingwood, and congratulations
on your new appointment as SCP-999's head
researcher, one of the cushiest and most enviable
assignments in the entire Foundation.
SCP-999 is one of the few anomalies in our
custody who will not only never attempt to
harm you but will actively try to save your
life if you’re ever in any danger.
Though your initial reaction when receiving
this assignment was no doubt elation, you
may have thought it was odd that such a seemingly
low-risk position was assigned by the O5 council
directly.
If you had already heard rumors of this prior
to your assignment, you probably thought it
was mere nepotism; the O5s protecting their
friends and loved ones by giving them the
safest job possible."
Dr. Collingwood sat back in her chair, laughing
to herself and shaking her head.
She would never admit it, but she absolutely
had heard those rumors, even believed them
until it had happened to her.
"Unless you are so narcissistic to think that
someone on the O5 council must be your secret
admirer, you’ve likely realized that this
is not the case.
To understand why this is our concern, you
need to know about 999’s origins.
You may have noticed that its file makes no
mention of where it was discovered.
This is a deliberate omission.
If you’re not familiar with the mythology
of the Scarlet King, I suggest you read up
on him.
There’s plenty of unclassified information
on him in the Foundation database.
All that’s relevant for now is that he is
- to the best of our knowledge - the most
powerful malevolent entity in the Multiverse."
Her stomach dropped at the mention of The
Scarlet King.
She was right, this was all connected somehow.
She leaned forward, eyes darting across the
words with increasing intensity as she read
on.
"You've been with us since you were a research
assistant, Dr. Collingwood.
In that time, I assume you've heard many rumors
about some of the horrific things we do here
at the Foundation that you've never personally
witnessed.
I regret to inform you that these rumors are
true.
Or at least, they were.
A thaumaturgical cult calling itself the Children
of the Scarlet King enacted a ritual wherein
seven young girls became effigies for each
of the Scarlet King’s seven brides, allowing
them to bear his horrid offspring.
How they obtained the knowledge to perform
this ritual is unclear since all we ever recovered
were handwritten notebooks.
Superficial resemblances to some Sarkic practices
has led some to speculate that the Children
of the Scarlet King may have some ties to
modern Sarkic cults.
It's an interesting idea, but no concrete
evidence has ever been found to link the two.
Investigation into the matter is ongoing.
As for the ritual itself, each birth caused
more destruction than the last.
The writings of the cult’s priest predicted
nothing less than the Apocalypse if the Seventh
Bride gave birth, which could only be prevented
if Procedure 110-Montauk was performed without
fail each and every day.
To our seemingly great fortune, the notebook
contained detailed instructions on how 110-Montauk
was to be carried out.
Needless to say, we found this suspiciously
convenient.
Why would they devise a countermeasure to
prevent the very apocalypse they were trying
to invoke?
We needed more information regarding these
entities.
Fortunately, our archaeologists have unearthed
numerous tablets, scrolls, and artifacts of
the ancient Daevas.
They were a sadistic and warmongering people
who were granted unholy power and knowledge
by the Scarlet King as a reward for the death
and suffering they caused.
One of the Daevite tablets in our possession,
found covered in dust and blood, was a theogony
for the Scarlet King and his Brides.
It was quite informative.
The information that we found most relevant
to our situation was that the Seventh Bride
was not like her sisters.
She was never completely broken by her King’s
subjugation.
Instead of monsters, she gave birth to great
heroes in the hopes that they would destroy
her sisters’ children and overthrow their
father.
Thus far, all have failed, but by a vote of
7 in favor, 6 against - admittedly more out
of concern for Procedure 110-Montauk's lack
of viability as a long-term containment strategy
than out of empathy for the girl - the O5
council decided to believe that the Seventh
Bride still remained unbroken and that her
child would be an asset to us.
At the risk of causing an XK-Class End of
the World Scenario, SCP-231-7 was relieved
from Procedure 110-Montauk following the deaths
of SCP-231-1 through -6, and was allowed to
give birth.
SCP-999 was the result."
Dr. Collingwood gasped, her hand flying to
her mouth.
A Research Assistant walking by her office
paused, looking at her curiously through the
window.
She waved them off with a forced smile, and
turned back to the screen.
Surely she couldn't have read that correctly?
But, no, there it was, plain as can be:
"Go ahead and read that again.
Be sure you understand it in all its preposterous
ridiculousness; The Tickle Monster is the
child of the Scarlet King.
We’ve been running a counterintelligence
campaign ever since, which is why everyone
and their mother thinks we’ve still got
a girl strapped to a rack in a bunker somewhere.
Let them think that.
Far better for everyone that the Children
of the Scarlet King believe that they’re
playing us for fools than for them to know
that there is a threat to their King.
The girl herself is fine, by the way.
She was cured of the trauma from her ordeal
by SCP-999, at which point it was decided
she could be returned to her family so long
as they were all given class F amnestics,
implanted with new identities, and relocated
to a town at least 1000 km away from the Children
of the Scarlet King's nearest known activity.
On the insistence of the Ethics Committee,
the family was also given a seven-figure payout
as compensation for our repeated…misdeeds
against their daughter, as were the families
of the other SCP-231s.
I suppose it was technically malpractice on
our part.
In case we have any moles for the Children
of the Scarlet King in the Foundation, as
far as anyone else knows 231-7's family were
killed in front of her as part of 110-Montauk.
I’m sure you’re skeptical.
Are we insane?
How could our sweet little tickle monster
ever hope to dethrone a Lovecraftian Horror
of unparalleled might?
Well, SCP-999 is less than a decade old.
It’s still just a child, and nowhere near
its full strength.
Even so, its power is incredible.
Even brief interaction with SCP-999 can permanently
cure severe depression and PTSD, and more
recent experiments have resulted in the complete
reformation of D-class personnel who were
previously unrepentant sociopaths.
This effect is not chemical, but psychic,
and one day it may grow powerful enough that
not even the Scarlet King himself will be
immune.
The experiment with SCP-682 was most remarkable.
Based on multiple Daevite texts, including
descriptions from SCP-140 itself, we are reasonably
certain that 682 is the offspring of the Fourth
Scarlet Bride.
If this is true, then SCP-999 is already strong
enough to temporarily quell the malevolence
of its own eldritch siblings.
One day 999 could very well be strong enough
to permanently reform its family members just
as it reforms human beings.
It will not overthrow the Scarlet King by
force, but with light and love and laughter
that can brighten the blackest of hearts.
999 is not, in reality, a safe class SCP.
It is Thaumiel.
It is the best and really the only weapon
we have against some of the most powerful
hostile entities known to exist.
By all means, doctor, enjoy the relative safety
of your new position, but do keep in mind
that SCP-999 is not a mere pet that we fancy.
It is one of our most valuable assets and
must be safeguarded at all costs.
Its safety and well-being are paramount, and
you are not at liberty to share this information
to anyone without level 5/999 security clearance.
As per protocol, unauthorized disclosure of
level 5 classified information will result
in your termination.
This e-mail will automatically delete as soon
as you leave the terminal, so feel free to
reread it as many times as necessary to remember
all of the pertinent information.
Take good care of our little tickle monster.
The fate of the Multiverse may well depend
on it.
- Your secret admirer (if anyone asks), O5-1."
Dr. Collingwood let out a long, slow breath
as her mind did its best to process everything
she just read.
The message looked official, and, when she
really thought about it...this all made a
twisted kind of sense.
What could SCP-999 possibly be, if not some
sort of mythic hero of divine prophecy?
What other explanation could there be for
something so utterly, perfectly good?
Maybe one day that happy orange slime would
save them all, and do it with a smile.
But for now, it was just a little, innocent
child.
No need to burden it with talk of heroism,
of epic battles between good and evil.
For now, she would just pour SCP-999 a heaping
bowl of M&Ms, give it a gentle pat, and say
"thank you."
The tickle monster gurgled excitedly in response,
nuzzling his new head researcher's hand.
He didn't understand what she was thanking
him for, but he appreciated it all the same.
SCP-106 is like something out of a night terror.
That gray, rotting flesh, those wide, empty
eyes like those of a shark, the relentless
corrosion and decay that follows him everywhere.
But what if I told you that, beneath that
horrifying exterior, was a heartbreaking,
tragic backstory?
Some of our more eagle-eyed viewers know that
SCP-106 has a wide variety of potential origin
stories, different events that may have led
to the Old Man we all know and fear today.
So, this is just one of several hypothetical
backstories.
With that little caveat out of the way, it's
time to see if we can bring a tear to your
eye with the tragic tale of SCP-106.
Back in the year 2000, Dr. Robert Scranton
and his wife, Dr. Anna Lang, were Head Researchers
at Site-120.
The two of them shared a lot of things: a
home, a life, a shared love of Bon Jovi songs,
but one of the things they had in common was
a passion for experimental research.
The two worked together to develop a device
called the "Lang-Scranton Stabilizer", which
was an early prototype of the Reality Anchors
used by the SCP Foundation to this day.
During a round of routine tests, an earthquake
unexpectedly struck Site-120.
Dr. Scranton was working in Reality Lab A
when the ground beneath him began to rumble.
The LSS shook from the activity, components
sliding out of place or breaking off altogether.
By the time guards, and Dr. Lang, arrived
to inspect the scene, both Dr. Scranton and
the LSS Control Panel were gone.
Upon his disappearance, Dr. Scranton was initially
presumed dead.
However, five years, eleven months, and 21
days later, his whereabouts became clear.
On December 23, 2005, the LSS Control Panel
reappeared in Site-120's Reality Lab A. It
was covered in unknown organic matter, and
reeked of vomit, blood, and death.
As Dr. Anna Lang waded into the area, against
the warnings of her colleagues, she was overwhelmed
with grief and horror.
She choked back tears as she accessed the
control panel, retrieving the audio files
left there, and realized that Dr. Scranton
had been keeping a log of his time in whatever
place the disaster had sent him.
The husband she had lost had, in a way, come
back to her, but she could not see him.
She could hear his voice, but where was he?
There was so much blood, so much unidentified
organic matter.
It looked like something had exploded onto
the control panel, and she didn't want to
think about what, or who, that could have
been.
As Robert's wedding ring fell to the floor,
landing in the muck, the emotional strain
became too much for Dr. Lang.
She collapsed onto the ground, hitting her
head on the pavement.
Dr. Lang survived her fall, left only with
a tender spot on her skull, and a wealth of
questions she was almost too afraid to answer.
But she had to find out, with answers at her
fingertips, she had to know what had become
of her dear Robert.
So, with the help of the other Site-120 Researchers,
who promised to step in when it became too
painful, Dr. Lang began to go through the
audio archives left behind by her lost love
in the years since he had vanished.
For the first eight days, Dr. Scranton didn't
speak.
At least, not in any recognizable words.
He hyperventilated, he muttered to himself,
he sobbed, he screamed with pure rage and
despair, but he didn't say a word.
He paced around the new space, clawing for
a way out, throwing his shoulder against any
hard surface he could in an attempt to bust
open a door, but he was trapped.
On his eleventh day in the pocket dimension
outside of any world he knew, Dr. Scranton
began to speak.
He reminded himself, reminded anyone who might
some day listen, who he was: Robert Scranton.
Age 39.
Born September 19, 1961.
Favorite color, blue.
Favorite song, "Living on a Prayer."
Wife, Anna.
Every day, he repeated these simple truths,
seeking comfort in his memories of Anna and
the life they once shared.
Her green eyes, their wedding day, her dressed
in white shoving a piece of cake into his
face with a giddy laugh and a sparkle in her
eye.
He hoped that she was okay, that she had managed
to escape the chaos with her life, that she
had been spared a similar fate.
He repeated her nickname, the password he
had set for the control panel: "Anna bo banna."
At this point, he realized that the machine
was still recording.
He called out for help, desperate to see if
anyone could hear him.
"Is anyone there?!
Hello?
Anyone?
ANYONE?!"
But of course, there was no answer.
"Why the hell is this thing even working,
it can't be working."
He mused.
"What the hell?!"
He couldn't see anything, not the switches
or the knobs, only the blinking of the red
"recording" light.
He was growing hungrier and thirstier by the
day, and though he knew he should be dead
from dehydration by now, somehow he wasn't.
He was still alive.
Soon, he found the controls, and determined
he had been trapped in this place for two
weeks, three days, forty-seven hours, and
fifty-eight minutes.
He realized at this point that, no matter
how hungry he got, no matter how long he went
without water, he would not die.
Somehow, in this place, his body kept going,
his heart ticked along, far past what should
have been his expiration date.
He retrieved a small picture of Anna from
his pocket, gazing at her face by the faint
glow of the red light.
Two months, four days, and three hours in,
he recorded a formal message:
"My name is…
Robert Scranton.
I am a former Head Researcher of Site…
120, a Foundation facility dedicated to studying
various reality-bending SCPs, for the purpose
of developing more advanced countermeasures
towards such threats.
For the last… red light, speak to me,
'Two months, eight days, sixteen hours'
What red light said.
I have been trapped in what I believe to be
an empty pocket dimension.
Alone.
Yeah… alone.
All alone.
I'm calling this place SCP…
I don't know, I can't remember where we are,
screw it.
I don't know what's happened in the past…
red light, please, again.
Two months, eight days, sixteen hours.
But…
no one else is around to argue, and at this
point…
I'm just talking into this control panel to
keep myself together.
I…
I need to keep a record.
There might be some poor chump in the future
who ends up like me, and… if this ever actually
makes it out… maybe, maybe I can help stop
that from happening.
That's all I have going for me right now,
and I really need something to go for, hahahaha…
…So, yeah, Robert…
Scranton…
documenting a new SCP for… future research
purposes.
That'll have to do.
Here we go!"
A few days later, he added to his informal
SCP log:
"I don't know if we could… contain wherever
I am.
It's… definitely not on Earth.
To be honest I don't know where it is.
I…
I think it has do something with the Stabilizer
prototype…
I'll explain that more later.
Okay… um… yeah, wherever I am, I don't
think it can be contained much as… created.
No, no, that's not the word I'm looking for.
Um… entered.
Yeah, entered is better.
I came into this place because of some really
bad reality-bending accident and… no, no,
Robert, don't be like that yet, you don't
know if there's no exit yet.
This place…
It's some sort of reality gap, I think.
It's dark.
Really dark.
As in, this little red light that shows my
words are actually being recorded is the only
visible light in this entire place.
I can't see my hands, and I can barely see
the control panel here.
I've had to basically use the light as a center,
and remember how many steps I take and in
which direction.
I haven't gone past a hundred yet.
I'm too…
I'm too scared to.
Heh.
I wonder if my hair is turning white, right
now?
I can't even see what color it is anymore.
Speaking of which, my head has been a bit
itchy recently.
If I don't concentrate on it, it's fine, but
I feel this… tingling all over my face.
I'm not sure why.
I… just discovered a new property of this
place.
All this time, I've been thinking I might
be walking on… some sort of… flat ground,
if you will.
I kept eye contact with little red as far
as I could see, and it seems I could walk
in a straight, flat path.
Jesus, my head is buzzing right now, I think
the adrenaline is still kicking…
But, if my hypothesis is correct, and this
really is some sort of reality… void, then
there shouldn't be anything to walk on.
Now that I think about, the whole time I've
been in here, it's felt like…
I'm walking, but I'm also swimming through
something.
It's like I'm walking through really thick
black gel.
There's enough tension to keep me on a…
"surface", but if I… imagine myself pressing
down hard enough, I can descend.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, I think…
I think I need to test this more, I'll be
back.
Two months, seventeen days, two hours.
Navigation is largely affected by… conscious
impulses to travel in a certain direction.
So, this definitely isn't a complete reality
gap, at least according to mine and Anna's
theories.
If-if it were I wouldn't have been able to
move at all, since space wouldn't have existed.
Holy shit, okay, okay, this makes a lot more
sense than it did before, great, great job,
Robert, you're getting there.
…Come to think of it, I should've realized
that sooner when I was able to move in a flat
plane to and from little red.
It also explains why I'm not dead from dehydration
or hunger yet, time barely passes in here.
Okay yeah, so, I stood right next to little
red, and went straight…
"down."
Okay, from here on out, imagine little red
as the origin of a 3D space.
I went straight…
down, right, yeah, and then… and then I
was then able to come back "up" to little
red again.
I've also been able to "fly" above red.
Movement in here is slow, like I said, gel
analogy, best I can describe it by."
As Robert became more familiar with his surroundings,
with the truth of where he found himself,
something became clear: Of all the things
in this new reality, he and his little red
light were the realest.
With time, they would begin to degrade, to
fall apart.
He had, in estimation, three years before
he would be gone for good.
He had to try and look for an end to this
place, a way out.
What did he have to lose?
As it turned out, what he had to lose was
himself.
He couldn't feel his legs anymore, couldn't
keep a grip on his own body.
He ran in one straight line for six months,
but found no edge, no end in sight.
He went down for eight months straight, and
never hit bottom.
His sole companion was the little red light,
and he continued to talk to it as if it could
ever answer.
His hands began to phase into each other,
his thumb came off without any pain, the integrity
of his form beginning to fade and warp.
No matter what happened to him, he could not
die.
His sanity began to crumble, his voice breaking
into uncontrollable sobs and hysterical laughter.
Whoever Robert Scranton had been, he was gone.
He was something else now, and who knew how
long that new thing would last?
For the next twenty-five years, Dr. Anna Lang
tried her best to put the thought of her lost
husband out of her head.
It almost worked some days, she almost forgot
that hole in her heart.
Then, one fateful day, Site-120 received a
deadly visitor.
SCP-106 reached through the back wall of her
lab, dripping its horrible rot all over the
floor.
It grabbed for her, its touch melting her
lab coat as she tore away from its toothless
grin, the singular focus in its milky eyes.
The old man chased her down, pushing past
a guard's bullets, tearing through everything
in its path.
She had done enough work on dimensional anomalies
to recognize one when she saw it, and this
was one of the most destructive she had ever
encountered.
When it finally caught her, it said one word:
"Red."
Then, another, one that made her eyes fill
with tears.
"Anna..."
Dr. Robert Scranton had found a way to escape
the dead-end prison he had fallen into, that
gap between the worlds.
All it had taken was giving up his humanity,
letting that world rearrange his atoms and
make him something monstrous, something that
destroyed all it touched.
He couldn't remember why he needed to find
Anna, how he had been separated from her for
so long, he could only remember that he wanted
her.
Wanted to be with her.
Wanted to touch her again, even as she screamed
and melted in his hands.
SCP-106 once was a man, just like any other
man.
What he is now shares the vague shape of the
human he used to be, the vaguest hints of
his memories, but that is where the similarities
end.
Like the rotting flesh of his body might suggest,
he is little more than a shambling corpse
with a ravenous appetite for violence.
Dr. Robert Scranton is dead, but he will never
rest.
Anyone who holds more than just a passing
knowledge of the SCP Foundation has likely
heard the name of one Doctor Jack Bright.
Like a lot of the other high-ranking research
staff, his name carries with it a reputation
for anomalous expertise far beyond many working
at the Foundation.
Having risen through the ranks and achieved
the position of Personnel Director for Sites
17, 19, and 63, Doctor Bright may just seem
like a highly competent and devoted member
of the organization.
But the history of the man himself is one
that will be forever linked with tragedy and
trauma.
Jack Bright’s life has been turbulent, to
say the least, with themes of rebirth and
regeneration constantly following him and
his family… and all the curses that those
ideas bring.
Born to Adam and Evelyn Bright, young Jack
has sadly never experienced what many would
consider an ‘ordinary’ life.
You see, both his parents were also researchers
within the SCP Foundation, meaning that since
birth, Jack Bright has never known a life
that wasn’t linked with the Foundation and
its many anomalous happenings.
And it didn’t stop there either.
At some point, Doctor Adam Bright would rise
through the ranks of the Foundation, much
like his son would later come to do.
Adam progressed from researcher to personnel
director to site director and then eventually
even to the high station of O5 Council member.
But this career trajectory within the Foundation
was cut short when Jack Bright’s father
met an untimely end, assassinated on the orders
of his fellow O5 Council members.
But why?
What could have led to young Jack suffering
the loss of his Foundation employed father?
Well, it had to do with the other Bright children.
You see, Jack was far from an only child;
in fact, he had a considerable number of siblings.
While you might be forgiven for thinking this
would provide a younger Jack Bright with equals,
friends that he would at least endure his
anomalous adjacent childhood with, this was
sadly not the case.
One of Jack’s brothers, TJ Bright, was born
with his very own anomalous abilities.
TJ had something of a gift for healing, possessing
the power to absorb the injuries and illnesses
of anyone around him, purely through physical
touch.
But the unfortunate side effect is that TJ
also takes on another person’s ailments
himself, experiencing their pain and sickness,
so they don’t have to.
If you’re Jack Bright, it had to have been
hard to see your younger brother suffering
from wounds and diseases passed onto him so
that others don’t suffer.
But there’s still the lingering question:
what happened to jack and TJ’s father, Adam?
What led to his assassination, and what role
did TJ play in the events leading up to that
untimely death?
Well, like much of Doctor Bright’s family
life, it began with a tragedy.
Trying for another baby, Adam and Evelyn eventually
had a new daughter, giving Jack, TJ, and their
other siblings a new sister.
However, this was sadly short-lived, as the
newest member of the Bright family was stillborn.
Bearing witness to the grief that would have
caused his parents was no doubt hard on Jack.
But even more upsetting was what came next.
Naturally, having both studied anomalies within
the SCP Foundation, Evelyn and Adam were willing
to defy death itself in order to get their
newly born daughter back.
And luckily for them, they had been presented
with the perfect anomaly to achieve this goal,
in the form of their young son TJ and his
regenerative powers.
However, what resulted, was a creature that
later became known as SCP-321.
While TJ was able to revive the child, her
body aged at a rapidly accelerated rate.
She became devoid of melanin in her hair,
eyes, and skin.
Still able to vocalize but unable to intelligibly
speak, SCP-321 is known to have spatial awareness
issues, as well as a low level of intelligence.
On top of that, SCP-321 seemed to have inherited
some of her brother TJ Bright’s healing
abilities, capable of regenerating any injury
she suffers at five times the normal speed,
attributed to an overproduction of stem cells.
It was this that also caused her body to rapidly
age and grow, with no signs of stopping.
Taken in by the SCP Foundation and given a
designation – along with TJ, who became
known as SCP-590 – SCP-321 was separated
from the rest of the Bright family.
Adam, still a Junior Researcher at the time,
pleaded with his Foundation superiors for
his daughter to be released back into the
care of her family.
Every time he made the request, it was denied.
It didn’t seem to matter how much higher
up the managerial ladder of the SCP Foundation
Adam Bright climbed, there always seemed to
be a message from above telling him ‘no’.
In time, he was appointed to the O5 Council.
It was then that Adam Bright issued a mandate
for SCP-321’s immediate release… and the
rest of the Council didn’t take kindly to
that.
Trying to get his daughter back cost Adam
his life, and meant that young Jack Bright
had lost not only one of his brothers and
a sister, but his father too.
Jack Bright assisted the SCP Foundation with
keeping his brother TJ, or SCP-590, contained
for his own safety.
Unlike his remaining siblings, Jack still
seemed eager to follow in the footsteps of
his mom and dad.
Another of his sisters, Claire Pierce, was
angered by the Foundation’s actions and
how they had treated her family.
This caused her to join up with the Serpent’s
Hand, a Group of interest with the goal of
one day exposing the SCP Foundation to the
world.
Then there was Mikell Bright, who had the
opposite reaction to his sister.
He devoted himself to the Foundation, becoming
one of their most skilled and highly efficient
field operatives, known to some as Agent Cowboy.
Needless to say, there remains plenty of division
between the Bright siblings, something that
would undoubtedly exact a heavy toll on Jack,
who, for his part, continued his family’s
legacy by joining the Foundation as a Junior
Researcher.
This is where his life would once again be
altered forever…
To begin with, Jack seemed to have it easier
than most starting out at the SCP Foundation.
As previously mentioned, the Bright name already
carried significant pull within the organization,
not only allowing him to get his foot through
the proverbial door, but also giving Jack
a much-needed win after his past family troubles.
After all, he had a considerable amount of
emotional baggage and trauma to deal with,
so the up-and-coming Junior Researcher perhaps
deserved to coast by for a while.
Although it wouldn’t last long, and Jack
Bright would be irreversibly and irreparably
changed on one fateful day.
It was a seemingly menial task, a job that
could have been done by anyone else, and things
might have turned out completely different
if they had.
But yet, in giving it to a certain Junior
Researcher who was in good standing, the Foundation
completely reoriented the trajectory of Jack’s
life.
He had been assigned to perform research on
SCP-963, an ornate and rather beautiful amulet
of unknown origin and purpose.
The piece was constructed from elegant white
gold, sporting an oval cut ruby surrounded
by thirteen brilliant cut diamonds in a starburst
pattern.
It was a truly exquisite and well-crafted
piece of jewelry…
with a rather strange property to it.
Not yet realizing the active anomalous effects
of the amulet, Doctor Bright made the honest
mistake of touching SCP-963 with his bare
hands.
It was purely an act of human error, avoidable
and yet carrying consequences that would last
a lifetime… or several.
You see, as it so happened, the exact same
fateful day that Doctor Bright had made the
mistake of allowing SCP-963 to make contact
with his skin, another anomaly had simultaneously
managed to breach containment: SCP-076-2,
better known as Able.
The immortal warrior tore his way through
the Foundation, pulling his bladed weaponry
out of a pocket dimension and cutting down
any personnel in his path as he continued
his rampage.
When the slaughter was over, the dust clearing
and Able re-contained, Junior Researcher Jack
Bright lay dead, tragically slain during the
breach.
Or so it first seemed…
It was during the clean-up in the aftermath
of Able’s rampage, that a member of D Class
personnel named Tom Higly, was assigned to
dispose of the bodies left in the wake of
the undying warrior’s massacre.
That was when Tom unknowingly picked up the
amulet that Doctor Bright had been holding
when he was killed.
Instantly, the D Class suffered a peculiar
change, one that would soon become a regular
occurrence at the SCP Foundation: Tom Higly
became Doctor Jack Bright.
Once again, like with his brother TJ’s anomalous
powers and the tragedy of his stillborn sister
SCP-321, the theme of rebirth and regeneration
became a core part of Jack Bright’s life.
He was alive once again, and inhabiting a
new body.
Now, this might seem like a positive development
for the aspiring Junior Researcher.
But, as Jack Bright would soon learn, the
cost of coming back from the dead was a hefty
toll to pay.
After the Foundation had established that
the D Class now wearing the amulet was indeed
the person he claimed to be, they quickly
discovered that removing SCP-963 from the
wearer would cause all higher brain functions
to shut down immediately.
Replacing the amulet, the body of Tom Higly
was able to move and speak once again, albeit
with the voice and consciousness of Jack Bright.
Through his continued experimentation with
the artifact, Doctor Bright discovered that
it acted as a vessel for his consciousness,
his collected memories, and his personality.
They were all seemingly stored within SCP-963
and could be transferred into a new body when
the amulet was worn by someone else.
However, part of the high cost of Jack’s
newfound immortality was the immediate loss
of another person for the sake of his continued
life.
Placing the amulet on someone else would erase
everything about who they were, effectively
killing them and wiping them clean to make
room for Jack himself.
It was only thanks to his mistake of being
the last person to hold the amulet, along
with being killed by Able directly afterwards,
that had now led to Jack being unable to die.
Of course, the other large part of the cost
Jack had to pay for living forever was that
he essentially now had to live as a parasite,
passed on from host to host at a regular rate.
He learned that, after thirty days of sustained,
continuous contact with SCP-963, Jack’s
consciousness could become permanently affixed
to a new body.
If the amulet was removed after this occurred,
then Bright’s consciousness could still
be passed on to a new body, meaning he could
– in theory, at least – create multiple
copies of himself by transferring into new
host bodies via the amulet, and allowing them
to wear it for thirty days at a time to make
the change permanent.
Naturally, as they so often tend to do, the
SCP Foundation imposed sanctions and restrictions
to prevent this scenario from unfolding, executing
any hosts wearing the amulet before they could
reach this thirty-day permanent transfer threshold.
Afterwards, SCP-963 and Doctor Bright’s
consciousness would be passed on to a new
host, and the cycle would continue.
However, after witnessing the immortal researcher’s
continued dedication to their cause, the Foundation
eventually relaxed its rules for Doctor Bright.
Jack then went on to continue work with the
Foundation, rising through the ranks and achieving
promotions to higher stations, eventually
becoming one of the most well-known researchers
of SCPs to ever live.
But all the while, he did further examination
of SCP-963.
You might be fooled into thinking that immortality
would be a gift, but to Jack Bright, it’s
a never-ending curse.
Moving from host to host, only surviving because
of a simple mistake that changed his circumstances
in ways he could never have foreseen, Doctor
Bright lives in frustration and longs to be
free from what he views as a curse of eternal
life.
He is perpetually aware that he’ll outlive
everyone at the Foundation, have to watch
countless people die while he lives on.
Just like he had to live on after the death
of his father.
This curse of immortality has led Doctor Bright
to long for a permanent death.
Ironically, he only became a part of SCP-963
in a moment of trying not to die, and now
can’t at all, making the story of Doctor
Jack Bright a truly saddening tale.
As history often teaches us, sometimes human
beings are the biggest monsters of all.
Of course, when you join the ranks of the
SCP Foundation, that starts to seem even less
likely.
And why wouldn’t it?
After all, just look at some of the creatures
they encounter and keep in containment.
A giant unkillable lizard, a being with toothy
protrusions growing out of its body, a whole
host of immortal eldritch beings that could
destroy reality, and one sadistic old man
who drags unsuspecting victims into his own
personal hellscape.
Monsters are a dime a dozen to the Foundation,
humanity could never be anywhere near as evil
or as cruel as the real monsters, even on
their worst day.
Or at least, you’d think.
Researcher Keltzen had held much of the same
mentality, that the SCP Foundation had the
job of defending humanity from the real monsters
of the world.
And it was because of that belief that he
had never previously questioned the Containment
Procedures in place for SCP-1000.
These beings were a species of nocturnal and
omnivorous apes, usually with bodies covered
in either grey, brown, black, red or white
fur.
Possessing the same level of intelligence
as the common chimp, the SCP-1000s had been
colloquially described as a species known
as ‘Bigfoot’, linking them to the urban
legend about an ape-like being of dubious
existence.
Keltzen had hardly been surprised that Bigfoot
itself was an anomalous SCP.
There were already a number of others that
the Foundation had encountered that seemed
to have influenced popular folklore from different
parts of the world.
In fact, it was that unique sub-category of
anomaly that Keltzen was conducting research
into when he came across the SCP-1000 files.
He was trying to determine, in various cases,
which came first: the anomaly, or the legend?
Did the existence of SCP-1000s inspire earlier
human civilisations to pass on stories of
the Sasquatch?
Or had those word of mouth tales been somehow
to the very origins of SCP-1000 themselves?
Studying the files, Keltzen knew there was
a memetic disease infecting hominids like
SCP-1000.
The infection meant that anyone who observed
one of the Bigfoot creatures had at minimum
a 2% chance of suffering instantaneous brain
death.
It would make discovering the link between
the Sasquatch legends and SCP-1000 difficult,
not being able to directly look at the apes.
But Keltzen hoped he wouldn’t need to actually
observe the creatures, only find evidence
that proved which predated which: SCP-1000
or the legend of Bigfoot.
The population of SCP-1000 was limited, although
their highest concentrations were known to
be found in the Pacific Northwest region of
North America, as well as in the Himalayan
Mountain range in Asia.
Being stationed at a Foundation facility in
the US, Researcher Keltzen opted to mount
an expedition to the former location.
A few odd occurrences had taken place leading
up to his departure: his car tires had been
slashed, and now needed repairing.
Newspaper clippings were also left on Keltzen’s
desk that told of various hikers’ deaths
taking place in the Pacific Northwest.
A more paranoid person might interpret these
as subtle, indirect threats; it certainly
seemed as if someone in the SCP Foundation
wasn’t keen on Keltzen departing for his
research trip.
Nevertheless, he changed tact and called in
sick to work, sneaking away to a small airstrip
and boarding a light cargo plane that smuggled
him towards the forests of North America.
Once he had arrived, night was already falling.
Keltzen was on his own, traversing the woods
as the sun rapidly receded out of view behind
the treeline, leaving the forest in darkness,
save for the beam from his flashlight.
The researcher was hardly an outdoorsy type
and far from an expert at exploring the wilderness,
but he pushed on into the heart of the woods,
to the areas where the most sightings of SCP-1000
had been reported.
It wasn’t long before the torchlight fell
over something imprinted in the woodland floor:
a large footprint, left by something bipedal
and rather similar to an ape.
Venturing further, the sound of twigs breaking
caused Keltzen to whirl around.
The noise had come from nearby, making it
louder than the low, background ambiance of
the forest at night.
He swung his flashlight in the direction he
thought it had come from, only seeing the
shadows of branches cast against the tree
trunks.
Then, another noise, leaves rustling as something
passed by, followed by more snapping of twigs,
then the shaking of the leaves again.
This thing, whatever it might’ve been, was
encircling him.
Frantically, Keltzen tried to spot it with
his light.
When, suddenly, the beam fell over something
tall, a hulking figure moving between the
trees.
Even from that split second sighting, it was
clearly an instance of SCP-1000.
The momentary glimpse had reminded the intrepid
researcher of an important detail: he couldn’t
look at them.
A 2% chance of instant brain death seemed
too low to worry about, but Keltzen’s research
had described the effects of the memetic disease
to be cumulative: the longer an SCP-1000 ape
was observed, the higher the chance of being
killed on the spot by the infection.
Snapping his eyes shut as tight as he could,
Keltzen was frozen to the spot, at the mercy
of the sounds surrounding him.
The SCP-1000 was drawing closer, enough for
the researcher to detect its footsteps.
His pulse quickened, along with his breathing
to match.
Although he was already aware that the apes
weren’t known for being aggressive, but
hearing its heavy breathing as it drew nearer
was enough to make him uncertain.
Keltzen wasn’t sure if the Bigfoot would
attack him, or pass him by, but by far the
last thing he had expected…
was to hear it start speaking.
“Hu… man,” came a deep, gravely voice.
It was the kind of sound an animal makes that
can almost be mistaken for speech.
Keltzen wasn’t fully convinced it had been
a word, rather just his ears playing tricks
on him in a moment of heightened fear.
“Human,” it repeated, much clearer.
There was no mistaking it a second time: the
SCP-1000 had spoken.
“Y-you can talk?”
Keltzen exclaimed in disbelief.
The Sasquatch didn’t answer directly, instead
the researcher detected the sound of receding
footsteps.
There was a pause, as the SCP-1000 ape turned
back to Keltzen.
“Follow, human,” it said.
“Open your eyes and follow me.”
“What about the disease?”
Keltzen shouted, keeping his eyelids still
screwed shut.
“You’ll be safe,” the ape replied, before
it resumed walking away.
Cautiously opening his eyes and lifting his
flashlight, Keltzen could see the hairy figure
making its way through the forest, its back
to him.
He could see it; the researcher could look
directly at it and yet nothing seemed to be
happening.
No adverse side effects, no instant brain
death.
The odds were low, Keltzen reminded himself,
as he began to warily follow the path of the
ape.
Following at a distance, he made sure to momentarily
glance away, trying not to stare for too long
at the SCP-1000 creature, in the hope that
might disrupt the memetic effects of the infection.
Before long they had arrived at a cave, deep
in the heart of the forest.
The embers of a small fire were still aglow
near the rocky entrance.
As they lumbered inside, the SCP-1000 threw
extra wood on the fire, poking it with a long
stick until the flames began to reach higher.
The flickering orange gave Keltzen a better
look at the ape, its large frame, covered
almost head to toe in brown fur.
There was something about the creature that
seemed off, not unsettling but almost sad,
melancholic…
like it was lonely.
The researcher had been so amazed that he
could observe the creature for so long without
dying that he’d barely focused in on the
more important discovery: SCP-1000s were far
more intelligent than the Foundation files
had indicated, capable of not only speech,
but emotion too.
“D-do you have a name?”
Keltzen stammered, unsure where to start.
“Grykor,” it replied.
“That is my name.”
“You’ll have to forgive me, I’m a little
taken aback by all this,” the researcher
hastily explained.
“You’re able to articulate, your species
is advanced enough to have names.”
“Why should that be surprising?”
Grykor asked.
“Well, it’s just, the Foundation seems
to think you and your kind are…
I don’t mean any offense but, mindless beasts.”
The ape made a huffing, exhaling sound; Keltzen
noticed after a moment that they were chuckling,
a dry, almost sarcastic chuckle.
It was unlike anything he had expected to
learn about SCP-1000.
That reminded him of why he’d come here.
“Grykor, may I ask something?” he cleared
his throat.
Nodding, the SCP-1000 instance poked at the
fire again, paying little mind to the human
in its company.
“Where did you and your people come from?”
Keltzen asked.
“What’s your history?”
“Why?”
Grykor replied abruptly.
“You see, humans have these legends… stories
about something called Bigfoot, or a Sasquatch.
The Foundation, the humans I work with, they
call you one and the same.
I wanted to know if that was true.”
For a short moment, the creature paused.
Then, Grykor began to give Keltsen the truth;
the real truth.
And as they spoke, it was as if the researcher
could see the story unfolding, emphasized
by the pain in the ape’s teary eyes.
“We were like you, long, long ago,” it
began explaining.
“We and humans, we evolved together, side
by side.
For a time, there was peace between us.
But we began to grow faster, stronger, became
smarter while you were left behind.”
“You evolved before early humans did?”
Keltzen probed.
“Indeed,” Grykor answered with a gentle
nod.
“We began to surpass the humans.
You were still young, still hunting and foraging
for food while we were moving far beyond.
Thousands and thousands of years, we were
able to develop our culture, our technology,
all before the humans had even come close
to fire and the wheel.”
“But that doesn’t make any sense!”
the researcher interjected yet again.
“If that was the case, mankind would never
have had its chance to reach the top of the
food chain.
We would have died out, and that would have
made you the dominant species on the planet.”
“We were,” the SCP-1000 ape replied.
“For a time.”
“What happened?”
Grykor turned with a solemn look on their
face.
“You,” it replied plainly.
“Humans happened.
We covered the world, billions and billions
of us.
You were rare, as few as we are now.
My people made technology far beyond anything
humans have dreamt up; either before or since.
Trains, ships, vehicles created from the trees
and the animals.
Communication using parts of insects and smaller
creatures.
Cities filled with us, where we all lived
in harmony, stretched out across parts of
the world humans dared not to tread.”
“Organic technology,” Keltzen gasped.
“Fascinating!”
“We had weapons too.
And that was our biggest mistake.”
“What kind of weapons?”
the researcher quizzed the ape.
“Given how advanced you were compared to
humanity at that time, I’m assuming your
weaponry was far beyond our early spears and
clubs.”
“The devastating kind,” Grykor said, staring
ahead into the fire, almost as if the dancing
flames conjured up images of the kind of destruction
his ancestor’s weapons could cause.
“I think I understand,” Keltzen said.
“There was some kind of conflict, yes?
A majority of your people perished… oh,
my condolences.
But that would have removed you from the top
of the evolutionary chain, and allowed the
earliest ancestors of humanity to usurp your
place there?
Was the disease you and your species carry
a result of that war, a sort of lingering
radioactive fallout but on a genetic level?”
“We are not sick,” Grykor growled.
“Your people lied.
They made that up.
And there was no war…
it was a slaughter.”
Keltzen fell quiet, unsure of what to say.
“Humans would stay away from us back then.
We avoided them too.
You slept during the night when we were awake.
But you made a deal.
A deal with something ancient and dangerous
in the forests.
A deal to even the score.
You found our weapons… and didn’t hesitate.”
“No, that’s…” the Foundation researcher
tried to protest, but the look of sadness
on the ape’s face stopped his sentence before
he could finish.
“We were almost entirely wiped out, in a
single day.
Humans switched places with us, we became
less and they became more.
They used our technology to forget about us,
wiped their memories so they wouldn’t have
to face up to what they had done.
But we never forgot.”
“And the Foundation, they maintain that
façade,” Keltzen realised.
“That’s why they tell us you’re infected,
that if we look at you’ll we’ll die.
They’re ashamed, we…
we all should be.”
“Not just ashamed,” Grykor replied.
“Afraid.
They fear we want revenge, retribution for
what was done to our people.”
“And do you?”
The ape took another pause, as if it was pondering…
or just allowing itself a moment to feel sad.
“We have forgiven you,” it answered.
“I’m not sure we deserve that,” Kletzen
said back, as the pair sat by the fire until
the sun came up.
It's rare for the SCP Foundation to encounter
an anomaly that volunteers information about
itself, that seems to actively desire to be
studied, to be investigated, to be known.
But SCP-082 is one such anomaly.
SCP-082 calls himself Fernand, a giant man
with an even bigger appetite, and though he
is cheerful and chatty, even friendly by SCP
Foundation standards, it can be difficult
to sort the fact from the fiction where his
life story is concerned.
At various points in his containment, he has
claimed to be a vampire, a homunculus, Sherlock
Holmes, Alexander the Great, Dr. Frankenstein
and his Monster, Napoleon, and Big Bird, to
name a few.
But on October 27, 2016, Fernand made a particular,
unusual request.
He asked for a set of poetry books, a stack
of blank paper, and a quill.
He isolated himself for days, refusing to
eat, drink, or sleep as he wrote page after
page.
When he was finished, he had written a poem
that seemed to be the first honest exploration
of his life story since he was first contained
by the Foundation.
It can be difficult to determine when SCP-082
is lying, since he is always grinning widely
and claims to only lie when it is "through
his teeth," but after reading the aforementioned
poem aloud, he wept openly in what seemed
to be a genuine display of emotion.
According to the events described in the poem,
which should still be taken with a small grain
of salt, this is what Fernand's life was like
before he became SCP-082.
Fernand could not remember his earliest years,
what his parents or his childhood home might
have looked like.
His earliest memory was of a makeshift home
in an alleyway, a box to sleep in, and a bundle
of rags serving as a makeshift bed.
For food, he would steal day-old bread thrown
out by a nearby bakery, and catch birds and
rats that were slow enough for him to grab.
Even as a young boy, he was enormous, three
times the size of other boys his age.
His strength and stature made him appealing
to the workhouses at first, but they always
ended up throwing him out, calling him a monster,
le monstre.
After the third workhouse chased him into
the streets with whips, he resigned himself
to a solitary life in the shadows, down the
abandoned alleyways where not even the beggars
would go, so overrun were they were rats and
filth.
It was better for Fernand that way, no one
would try to mock him, to hurt him, to dispose
of the monster once and for all.
He spent his days and nights there, in the
little alleyway he had turned into a home,
keeping as quiet as possible out of fear that
he would be discovered by someone with ill
intentions.
One night, he got his hands on a row of meat
tarts left on a windowsill and ate to his
heart's content.
He slept unusually soundly that night, with
a full belly for the first time in a long
time, and without knowing it, he must have
begun to snore.
As the first soft beams of sunlight fell across
his face, stirring him from sleep, he heard
the sound of a strange man's voice.
Perhaps it was someone just passing by on
a nearby street?
But no, there was a shadow at the end of the
alleyway, blocking out some of the light.
He retreated out of sight, hoping to avoid
detection, but he could see two more blurry
figures stepping into his vision.
All of a sudden, they started running toward
him at top speed.
This was no accidental encounter, they had
spotted him and were targeting him specifically.
For what?
He didn't want to find out.
The giant boy climbed to his feet and tried
to run, but the alley was narrow, and the
three men grabbed hold of each of his arms,
while one grabbed his legs and forced him
to the ground.
Someone stuffed a dirty rag into his mouth,
muffling his cries for help, and out of the
corner of his eye, he saw the glint of a metal
pipe swinging at his head.
Then, everything went dark.
When Fernand opened his eyes again, all he
could see at first was red, vivid red on all
sides.
As his vision adjusted, he realized he could
see metal bars as well.
The red was fabric, bright cloth draped over
the iron cage that now held him prisoner.
He stumbled to his feet, forced to stoop to
avoid bumping his head on the top of the cage,
and rattled the bars desperately.
"Let me out!
Please!"
He begged, though he felt as though it was
useless.
His plea was not met with silence, however,
but with loud, cheerful music.
He covered his ears at the sudden noise, jumping
back, but it came from all sides, and there
was no escape.
Suddenly, his eyes were blinded by a sudden
bright light as the red cloth was yanked from
the cage in one swoop.
It took a moment for his eyes to adjust, but
as he blinked the tears from his eyes, Fernand
could make out a man with a large mustache,
a long red and gold coat, a matching top hat,
and a gold-tipped cane.
The man grinned at him, but it was not a friendly
face.
The smile did not reach his eyes, which glinted
with a cold, cruel delight.
Behind the ringmaster, Fernand could now see
a crowd sitting: men, women, and children
all watching him with rapturous fascination,
a mix of intrigue, disgust, and horror on
their faces.
He looked from face to face, seeking any kindness,
any sympathy, but found not one who looked
as if they might help him escape.
The music climbed to a crescendo, and when
it stopped, the ringmaster spoke.
"Ladies and gentlemen, boys and girls, today
I have brought you something the likes of
which no one has ever seen before!
I have traveled the world in search of oddities
and curiosities to delight and shock you with,
and after crossing every ocean, exploring
the furthest reaches of the globe, I have
brought you a very special gift!
Do not be afraid, the beast will not harm
you!
I will ensure that you are all perfectly safe.
Should he try anything at all, one of my helpers
here," he gestured to one of two large men
standing on either side of the cage, each
brandishing an ax, "Will simply strike him
with their axes!"
Fernand recoiled at the threat, but there
was nowhere for him to go in the cramped cage,
already a bit too small for his massive body.
The ringmaster continued his speech, pacing
back and forth in front of the cage and running
his cane across the bars with a horrible clattering
sound.
"As you can see, this creature looks like
a boy, but his statue reveals the truth: it
is something else entirely!
Something bigger, stronger, more vicious than
any child could ever be!
You see the legs like great tree trunks, the
arms strong enough to wrestle a bear!
But do not, dear audience, neglect to notice
its mighty jaws!
Like steel, strong enough to crush anything
it bites down on, strong enough to crack through
bone!
And the teeth...enormous and pearly white,
with a smile bright enough to light up the
darkness.
What do you say, beast, will you give the
people a smile?"
Fernand cowered in the cage, watching everything
with wide, frightened eyes.
He certainly did not feel like smiling.
When he did not budge, the ringmaster thwacked
his cane against the bars, making another
horrible metallic clang.
"Well?
These people paid good money to be here, do
not keep them waiting!"
After another moment of silence and Fernand
remaining stock still, the audience began
to boo, tossing empty popcorn bags and insults
at the cage.
The ringmaster leaned in close and whispered,
"Smile for the people, or I'll see to it you
suffer agony you could only dream of."
This threat snapped Fernand out of his frozen
terror, and, standing as tall as he could
in the little cage, he smiled wide, showing
all of his many, many teeth at once.
The audience erupted into cheers at the sight,
and the band played triumphant horns as the
ringmaster basked in the applause.
"How about that?"
The ringmaster took off his hat and bowed
low to the ground, holding out the hat for
the audience to toss in coins in a token of
their appreciation for an excellent show.
By the time the applause was finished, his
hat was filled with shiny silver and gold.
He tossed the hat, now heavy with new wealth,
to one of the guards, and pulled a gold-handled
whip from his pocket.
"Ah, but I haven't finished yet!"
He cracked the whip ominously, then turned
toward the cage.
He cracked the whip again, this time across
Fernand's back.
The boy roared in pain, a great bellowing
sound that carried for miles around, and fell
to his knees.
The sound was so loud, so powerful, that the
audience was terrified.
Small children began to cry, and people poured
from the circus tent in a panic, afraid the
beast would break free and tear them apart.
But there was no beast, only a frightened
boy who did not understand his own strength,
crying at the cruelty the world had shown
him all his life.
Once they were alone, the ringmaster turned
to Fernand again, catching his eye.
"Stop your crying, boy.
From here on out, you will be coming with
me.
Together, we're going to be very, very rich.
And I will make you a star.
Whether you want to be one or not."
And for a time, that became Fernand's life.
Night after night, crammed into a cage, fed
on chicken bones and leftover scraps, paraded
in front of uncaring audiences as the ringmaster
tormented him, showed him off as a sideshow
attraction, and forced him to smile with the
threat of the ax or the whip.
His fellow circus folk were not much kinder
than the ringmaster, either.
The clowns sprayed him with water and taunted
him through the bars.
The animal trainers threatened to pit him
against their lions and see who came out alive.
Only one person ever showed Fernand an ounce
of kindness at the circus, a bearded lady
who would sing opera songs in a beautiful,
clear soprano.
Her voice was the loveliest thing Fernand
had ever heard, a tiny slice of heaven in
the hell his life had become.
Days bled together as the tour went on, a
stretch of seemingly endless days and nights,
until the day of the last show came.
He looked up at the thin slivers of night
sky visible through the gaps in the tent,
the twinkling of stars just out of reach.
What would become of him after the tour ended?
What horrors awaited him next?
Would he just sit there and take it, or would
he finally do something to bring it all to
a close?
He flexed his muscles quietly, taking notice
of how he had grown over the past few months.
Regular feedings, more than he had gotten
on the street, had bulked him up considerably.
He now stood at over seven feet tall, and
could feel that his strength had doubled,
or even tripled.
The show began as it usually did, with the
crack of the ringmaster's whip.
But suddenly, the man stepped forward and
began a speech he had never made before.
"As you can see, this great beast cowers at
the sound of my whip!
Over the months, I have trained it, domesticated
it until it was aggressive no longer!
Behold, as I set it free!"
And, to Fernand's shock, the ringmaster unlocked
the door to the cage and swung it open.
He took a tentative step out, standing at
his full height for the first time in months
as he stretched his spine straight.
"See how it is tamed!
Go on now, boy!
Smile for your public!
They've been so good to us."
He jabbed Fernand's ribs with his cane, hard
enough to leave a dark purple bruise.
"You heard me, smile!"
The whip cracked again, and the audience began
to boo and jeer, throwing their garbage at
Fernand.
A bag hit his cheek with a slap, and a deep,
dark, rage finally awoke beneath the months
of terror.
"You remember our agreement, do as I say,
or I shall cut off something you’ll miss!"
Before the ringmaster could say another word,
Fernand grabbed him and pulled him into a
bone-crushing embrace.
The man's voice came out in a squeak, "Beast,
what are you doing?"
"That!
Is!
Not!
My name!"
Fernand bellowed, and he opened his mouth
wide, wider than he ever had before, and gobbled
up the ringmaster in three quick bites.
The audience screamed, fleeing from their
seats, but Fernand moved faster than they
did.
He grabbed person after person, starting with
those that had been the cruelest and shouted
the most insulting things, and devoured them
one by one.
When he was full, he ran into the night, into
the forest, and did not stop until he was
free.
He bathed in the river, washing away all that
he had done, and remained there for quite
some time, feeding on passersby when his hunger
got the better of him.
His sense of time grew fuzzy then, and he
could not be sure how long he spent there.
But word of missing townspeople eventually
reached a special organization, one dedicated
to studying those like him, and for the second
time in his life, Fernand was taken into custody
by strangers.
However, these scientists were much kinder
to him, and never called him a beast.
They simply gave him a number, SCP-082.
Doctor Trebuchet sighed, his breath fogging
up the visor of his hazmat suit.
He did a last-minute spot check, making sure
he had his clipboard and pen.
Then, he reached for the shoe box, feeling
its little occupant moving around as he lifted
it up.
The doctor turned as his newly appointed assistant,
Researcher Wachtel, barrelled into the room.
The researcher was late; Trebuchet couldn’t
imagine ever being tardy to his first assignment.
But the Foundation were insistent on training
up their new recruits as quickly as possible.
Exposure to a mostly harmless anomaly would,
in theory, help to normalize some of the stranger
SCPs that the organization dealt with.
Doctor Trebuchet held back a cheap shot about
Wachtel being so late, as the Assistant Researcher
hurriedly clambered into his own hazmat suit.
Both ready, they stepped through the decontamination
airlock after it had hissed loudly, sterilizing
the air and the outer layers of their suits.
Then, the two researchers continued into the
containment unit.
Even with their hazmat suits on, the differences
in temperature and humidity were instantly
noticeable, like the feeling you get stepping
off a plane after a long-haul flight.
The cylindrical glass enclosure had been perfectly
climate controlled, filled with wetland soil
and stagnant water.
It was like stepping inside a terrarium, a
tiny little pocket of swamp large enough for
someone…
well, something to comfortably live inside.
That something was SCP-811, sometimes known
colloquially by her nickname of the Swamp
Woman.
However, since bringing her into containment,
SCP-811 had given herself a different name,
which Doctor Trebuchet used when addressing
the slimy creature.
“Aé,” he greeted, causing SCP-811 to
turn and face the pair of Foundation personnel.
“Dockty, what want?”
she hissed – she had shown the capacity
for communication, but possessed a limited
vocabulary and struggled with the proper pronunciation
of words.
Doctor Trebuchet clarified he was there to
ask SCP-811 questions, to which she quickly
responded with a request for food.
Opening up the shoebox, a frog hopped out,
which the Swamp Woman quickly stomped on and
began to eat the dead creature.
Although, while she possessed a mouth, she
didn’t exactly ‘eat’ in the sense that
we understand it.
Her body secrets a slimy mucus that, upon
contact, causes a rapid rate of decomposition.
Much like a fly, SCP-811 will vomit onto things
in order to break them down so she can digest
their nutrients through absorption.
She uses this ability both to hunt, and as
a defensive countermeasure against attackers,
spitting out the waste of her food that collects
in her stomach.
Grinning at her own efforts, SCP-811 finished
her meal and indicated she was ready to continue
with questioning.
Doctor Trebuchet handed his clipboard to Researcher
Wachtel so that he could conduct the interview
as part of his on-the-job training.
“What is the earliest thing you can remember?”
Wachtel asked, reading from the board.
“Air-wee is thing?”
SCP-811 echoed; conveying that she didn’t
fully understand.
Wachtel stammered, unsure how to rephrase.
“Early things,” Doctor Trebuchet interjected.
“Things…
before.”
“Before box?”
Aé seemed to be understanding, indicating
her containment chamber.
“Before before box,” Trebuchet confirmed.
Appearing thoughtful for a moment, SCP-811
asked: “Most before?”
Doctor Trebuchet nodded vigorously, telling
her ‘Yes’; even though the Foundation
had mandated this interview, he genuinely
wanted to know how she had become like this.
Immediately, SCP-811 gave sweeping, demonstrative
gestures with her hands and described – in
very vague levels of detail – a man.
A man who had been taller than Aé herself,
at a time when she was also much, much smaller.
“Was like man,” she said, pointing at
her own arm.
“What was like him?”
Doctor Trebuchet probed, trying to clarify
what she meant.
In response, Aé pinched her mottled green
skin, its surface slick with mucus.
“This!
Not like Aé.
Like man.
Like people!”
she insisted.
Her skin, she had meant her skin had used
to look human.
Upon hearing the word‘ skin’ from the
doctor, SCP-811 repeated it, prodding at her
arm, and then smiled; she’d learned a new
word.
When questioned further by Doctor Trebuchet
– while Wachtel felt increasingly uneasy
nearby – the Swamp Woman pointed to the
inside of her elbow.
She described what she had experienced after
this tall man had approached her:
“Pain stick here.
Cold,” Aé said.
“Needle, Aé,” Doctor Trebuchet encouraged
her to use the right word, certain she meant
she had been injected with something.
“They’re called needles.”
“Knee-doll here,” SCP-811 tried to mimic
the sounds of the word, before then going
on to explain that she had experienced intense
pain soon after.
With her hands, she started miming that something
had come out of her mouth.
“Red.
Red, red, red.
Was… very hunger-y.
Ate man.
Skin… like this.”
Hearing her describe, even in loose, broken
terminology, what had happened to her, became
too much for Assistant Researcher Wachtel.
As far as both he and Doctor Trebuchet understood
what Aé was telling them, she had been injected
with something while still a child, and then
had… eaten the person responsible.
Wachtel, who had children of his own, couldn’t
help but imagine the same horrible act happening
to his own kids; and the thought of it made
him vomit in his hazmat suit.
Given her own chosen method of attacking and
dissolving prey, SCP-811 couldn’t help that
she interpreted seeing Wachtel throwing up
as an act of hostility.
It alarmed the Swamp Woman, causing her to
hurriedly retreat to a nearby pool of stagnant
water within her containment chamber, refusing
to remerge until Wachtel and Doctor Trebuchet
had left.
Angered by the Assistant Researcher’s lack
of professionalism and how it had interrupted
the most coherent explanation of SCP-811’s
past, Doctor trebuchet filed a dissatisfied
note with the SCP Foundation.
It read:
“While I understand the appeal of training
the new blood on something relatively harmless
and as green as they are, could you please
throw them at some other humanoid for a while?
I'm trying to actually get things done here.”
Had Wachtel been able to stomach what he had
heard SCP-811 saying, and probably through
more extensive interviews with the creature,
Trebuchet could have learned the full extent
of how the Swamp Woman had come to be.
She had been able to give the broad strokes
of it, of course, but her descriptive ability
was limited.
The story had definitely fit with what the
Foundation already assumed to be the case;
that, at some point, Aé had been human.
But what they hadn’t been aware of was the
actions of this unknown individual – a nameless
man – or what he had injected the young
girl with in order to trigger her transformation.
At any rate, the only explanation the Foundation
had was the word of SCP-811 herself.
It was vague at best; at worst it might not
have even been recalled with any degree of
accuracy.
She could have been lying, if she even had
the capacity to lie.
And the specifics of who she was before, why
someone had injected her and what with, were
all still a complete mystery to the Foundation.
And not just to them either.
Given her partial comprehension, SCP-811 had
long been suspected to have grown up as a
feral child, a youngster abandoned when they
were only a few years of age, rather than
as an infant.
It certainly seemed to explain her limited
understanding of human language; the fact
she could communicate at all implied she had,
at some point, lived among other humans, but
hadn’t fully developed before her transformation.
But even if she had been able to communicate
at an adult level, SCP-811 still wouldn’t
have given the full story to Doctor Trebuchet.
Not because she was keeping things from him,
but because she simply couldn’t.
The trauma of growing up alone in the swamp,
being turned into a monster, and everything
else that had come before, were all too much
for her.
She had, at some point, suffered a mental
break, her mind shutting off the full details
of her past as a defense mechanism.
The Swamp Woman had been through far more
– and far worse – than even she could
remember.
And, unbeknownst to the girl who would later
come to call herself Aé, the SCP Foundation
had been involved…
It had all started way back, a long time ago,
and many, many miles away from where it would
eventually lead to the birth of the Swamp
Woman.
Specifically, it began in Siberia.
The SCP Foundation had learned of an infectious
skin disease that had been discovered there
by GRU Division P, the Russian government’s
own anomaly containment organization.
They had encountered a virus that was highly
contagious, and that would spread on direct
contact with organic matter.
But that was far from the extent of it.
This infection would begin to transform its
host, turning them into a horrific fleshy
mutation that would attack any non-infected
life form in an aggressive attempt to spread
the virus further.
The Foundation called it SCP-610, although
the GRU P troops had a different name for
it: roughly translated, they called it ‘The
Flesh That Hates’.
Now, it was only through a combined effort
between the SCP Foundation and their Russian
counterparts in GRU Division P that this disease
was contained to a single, isolated area within
Siberia where it had first been discovered.
The Russian government at the time had agreed
to keep the area under their watchful eye,
and that anyone who became infected by SCP-610
would be killed immediately.
Of course, nobody had accounted for the one
who would get away.
A Russian operative, a researcher within GRU
P, had become obsessed with SCP-610 since
its discovery.
The virus itself was horrific, producing abominable
nightmares, but it could transform human physiology
in mere moments, producing fleshy creatures
that were almost unrecognizable as people.
This scientist began to wonder, if this transformative
property of the virus could somehow be controlled,
programmed even, then it may well hold the
key to some of the greatest breakthroughs
in medical science.
He envisioned using it to grow replacement
limbs out of tissue cells, or to trigger the
reconstructive regeneration of bodily damage.
The scientist just needed to figure out how
to prevent SCP-610 from fully transforming
someone; the only problem was anyone infected
with it was killed.
So, he took it upon himself to sneak into
the isolated area in Siberia, where he could
steal a sample of SCP-610 from the body of
a recently terminated mutation.
And he nearly made it away unscathed…
The scientist’s plans were quickly discovered
by the joint effort between the SCP Foundation
and GRU P. He had been requesting a sample
through the official channels for months,
and now he had taken one to experiment with
and gone on the run with a new identity.
Calling himself ‘Alec Holland’, the scientist
fled the Foundation-Russian agents sent to
pursue him.
As far as he knew, they were trying to prevent
him from carrying out what he viewed to be
a noble endeavor.
But the Foundation knew that, if even that
tiny sample of SCP-610 was able to spread,
it could cause a worldwide catastrophe.
Whilst piloting a small plane, Alec was shot
down over the swamplands of Louisiana.
By the time Foundation operatives arrived
in the area, all they found was a burning
wreck.
Little did they realize, Alec had been rescued
by locals, who had taken him aboard their
fan boat and rushed him to hospital.
He would later leave, before his injuries
had fully healed, and returned to the site
of the crash to discover something curious.
His sample of SCP-610 had been cross-contaminated
with the swamp’s stagnant water, teeming
with algae and who knows what else.
Alec was running out of time.
He knew that, if his wounds didn’t kill
him, he would soon be discovered by the Foundation
and GRU P. Using a syringe, he gathered up
the combination of the virus sample that had
mixed with the natural properties of the swamp.
There was no way of knowing what it would
do, whether it would still mutate a person,
or whether the disease’s transformative
effect had been altered.
But he had to know, and he was living on borrowed
time.
Desperate, he raced to the nearest town, a
tiny community near the swamp.
The first person, Alec told himself, the first
person he encountered would be his test subject.
He had to see what effect this altered version
of the virus would do to a human being.
It just so happened that the first person
he encountered was a little girl named Aé.
And he wouldn’t live long enough to see
the full extent of what he was about to turn
her into…